auf den lichtschalter macht das licht
aus und wir sehen ein neuer tag neues
glück
was geht da lugt uhr herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen blog ich war
gerade schon duschen und zähneputzen ich
vergessen immer nur um die kinder sind
wieder stars aus den mund ich weiß nicht
ob ihr euch noch an die spitze vor
einigen blogs ändern können die hier bei
uns im kinderwagen ja diese spinne liegt
jetzt alle tot
auf dieser uhr also ich mir die trotz
ziemlich etwas oder ich mache gerade
waren weil in beiden fällen noch mal in
meine wohnung ist aber müsli mit beeren
und melonen also schmeckt glaube ich
ganz neues
ja ich bin echt ganz klar habe ich meine
damen und herren auch noch bedeckt ist
noch wo die eine zerrissene jeans weiße
socken und das wird in der behinderte
stimmt ich bin zurück in meine freunde
hier das hier ist aber ich weiß auch
schönes auto oder klettern an den ganzen
glitzerndem zehn meter abstand weg und
dass ich wieder in köln angekommen bin
kleine planen darum meine damen und
herren ich wollte eigentlich erst nach
hause meine wohnung fahren hier in köln
die ganzen sachen die ich hier
eingelagert haben meine wohnung pakt mit
allerdings war jetzt direkt zur
sternfeld
aber alles eigentlich mag ich bin jetzt
gerade bei holy mehrspur gerade hier die
muster angekommen sind für den ersten
zwölf wo er immer wieder eine neue
kollektion intershop auch der fc auf
jeden fall kommen an produkten einen
überraschungs produkt was nicht so nötig
mache das gibt's ja immer und dazu
kommen noch zwei sich weiter ein t shirt
und einen pulli und bei dem rudi weiß
ich noch nicht welche farb kommen in den
shop packen soll deswegen hatten wir
jetzt die idee dass ich euch jetzt
einfach mal die drei verschiedenen
farbkombinationen zwischen den ich
gerade so ein bisschen hin und her
schranke dass ich dir jetzt einfach mal
zeigen und ihr dürft gleich über eine
abstimmung funktion entscheiden welches
produkt in den shop kommen wird also
dass hier sind die drei verschiedenen
farbkombinationen die ich für den rudi
mir ausgesucht hatte also einmal hier
sondern etwas so ein sanfteres gelb dann
hier so ein besseres pink und so ein
besseres babyblau das heißt hier findet
jetzt hier oben ihnen wohnen abstimmungs
funktion eingeblendet hat jetzt drauf
klicken oder könnt ihr entweder für gelb
abstimmen für pink oder für blau ich
weiß dass die farben nicht genau gelb
blau heißt also ich glaube das ist
verständlich sein und dann dürft ihr
quasi entscheiden welches von diesen
drei produkten am ersten zwölfter de
luca shop erscheinen wird also will ab
über die abstellung funktion
wir sehen uns wir sind fertig bei
hollywood schon gesehen habt habt ihr
noch nicht viele produkte gesehen
sondern nur den holy für mich geht es
jetzt erst mal nach hause oder welche
ganze sache näher erstmal auspacken
[Musik]
ich bin wieder zu hause angekommen
freunde und warum ist es überall so
fucking kalt auch einmal dello hat jetzt
hier auch endlich seinen wohlverdienten
platz beim kleineren losen band jetzt
gerade im block geschnitten ihr vor zwei
tagen gesehen hat und jetzt bestelle ich
will essen haben wir haben hier am
bahnhof oder aber vorplanung nächstes
mal bitte nicht so viel ich habe auch
gegessen essen war sehr lecker aber
freunde ich hasse diesen schrank alt und
ich habe hier diesen schrank diese
rechten stammtischen auf mache alles
cool aber wenn ich diesen stand wieder
zu machen
wir hoffen es ist mit jemand 40 minuten
lang versucht den schrank zu sein da
wird aber nein wir sind einfach nicht
funktionieren auf jeden fall kommt jetzt
noch eben partie vorbei dass kollege von
mir wir wollten einfach um die fifa
spielberger die in der nähe war
partie war drei stunden da wir haben
über einfachen demonstrativ für gespielt
und uns über den abschlussball
unterhalten den ich nach ja ich habe
mich immer mal abschlussball also dann
bin ich offiziell bachelor es wird schon
ein bisschen dunkel draußen was ich aber
schon lange mal machen wollte war dass
ich diesen tisch also dass alles was
hier um quasi dem zumal steht diesen
durchgang zwar das wollte ich immer ein
bisschen aufräumen und so ein bisschen
production music mäßig machen
okay diese aufgaben für den stunde und
ich habe bisher nur das hier geschafft
sich für die außenwelt stoppen und dann
sehen uns wieder wenn das gefertigt ist
es sind jetzt immer so ca zweifels in
folge aber ich bin jetzt fertig und zwar
sind jetzt meine kleine studio ecke
nicht mal hier unten so aus also hier
ist jetzt das digital piano hier habe
ich jetzt ein paar bücher einfach
hingestellt hier mein alter controller
hier so ein paar kabel festplatten und
so hier habe ich so ein midi keyboard
fresh produce mit logic und so habe ich
meinen neuen controller magix er ich
meine beiden monitore aufgebaut und mein
macbook den amateuren das hier unten
sind alle der schuhkarton aber das ist
jetzt mehr oder weniger meine kabel box
hat noch ein bisschen anderer kram sie
eine lampe und alles in allem sieht das
ganze jetzt so aus also auf jeden fall
schon mal viel kleiner als vorher ich es
jetzt auf jeden fall noch eine kleine
schale müßig und danach werde ich ins
team gehen leider ohne max weil der
kamera steht ich bin hoffen weg ins team
weil ich bin ein sportlicher geht so
wenig geändert und ich bin ganz schön
kalt ich finde es nichts besseres als
den feierabend nachdem man den tag so
komplett der rede ich als andere sachen
machen wollte geschafft hat danach mit
schönen trainieren und fischen zu gehen
nämlich meine nachbarn zu gast in der
domstadt von wir hier vielleicht ein
motivationstrainer auf die führungsrolle
von nachbar darauf angesprochen warum
ich eigentlich immer oben an einem
küchentisch mit der kpd stelle ich mir
jetzt allerdings nur noch kurz was zu
essen warm machen werde und danach auch
direkt schlafengehen werde würde ich
sagen das ich an dieser stelle einfach
was geht ab luca einen schönen guten
morgen hier zum zweiten tag in diesem
blog übrigens habe ich mir gedacht ich
mach das demnächst nicht mehr so dass
sich aus dem bett aufstehen und so
weiter und so fort also klar natürlich
denn die blogs anfangen so am ersten tag
der im block gezeigt werde ich das
natürlich noch machen aber beim zweiten
tagen keine ahnung ich finde ich aber
sage ich bin jetzt macht gerade
renoviert es dir hier vorne alles klar
die gala wahrscheinlich schon sicher ein
gelände wir sehen und sahen
nein teilen geschenkt hat also ein
produkt für sich wird sagen dagegen
jetzt gleich direkt mal hin bevor wir
uns allerdings der sache wird man mache
ich jetzt erstmal ja ich kann das nicht
bevor du irgendwas sagte instagram eben
pushen
ja also mit einem laser luca ok go [ __ ]
my mittal weissbrodt guten groß und
schön smoothie richtiges konkreter
frühstück kommen wir zur sache auf die
ich alles schon gewartet habe glaube ich
uns was die sache die auch im titel
steht und zwar kümmern wir uns heute um
etwas und zwar um das original eick lady
knete die was kann die kirche kann was
diskriminiert die anderen kneten alter
das hat mir die zuschauer bei einem
fantreffen geschenkt und ich bleibe auf
den preis gekostet tatsächlich vier euro
95 also danke dass ihr mir einfach fünf
euro und frank nähte geschenkt sie
packen das ganze erstmal raus und
einfach so dass er sogar recht gut
geklappt wir haben hier drin jetzt so
eine box in einer schatulle in der die
knete versteckt sein soll und wir fahren
auf der anleitung steht schon dass man
die knete soll der hand hat dann macht
man knickt dann sieht man die
auseinander und dann dehnt sich wie ein
kaugummi ich vollidiot kann euch das
jetzt gar nicht richtig zeigen hier
steht original intelligente clay super
knete nacht leuchtet ist es gerade der
nacht alter also ich meine wir können
das ding jetzt auspacken das sieht dann
so aus und wir haben jetzt hier quasi so
einen klotz käse drin dem kamel sommer
hier aus der verpackung rausholen und
sich das ekelhaft an alter
jetzt halt nur ich habe jetzt hier diese
knete und jetzt auch ganz geil also die
kann man schon bald die kann man schon
lang ziehen allerdings ist das besondere
an dieser knete hat dass die nacht
leuchtet deswegen haben wir die jetzt
ausgepackt
ich würde sagen dieses nacht leuchten
das testen einer dann heute abend ich
muss jetzt auf jeden fall kurze im
ersten paket weg bringen das wird
allerdings nicht spannend sein deswegen
würde ich sagen sehen uns einfach nur
eine stunde wieder wieder so ausgeht
3 durch 93 durch 90 kommen soll
das richtig ja hallo was sagen sie heute
hier zum wetter in köln alles klar
gemacht jetzt irgendeinen trick bruder
von comcom besitzen legal unserem
skaterpark in köln und norman hat zwar
kein skateboard aber er wollte schon
immer mal skater ist ein herkömmlicher
wirtschaftswissenschaften
was sagen sie zu ihrer leistung als
skater ist der ausgang hier
schaut mal freunde ich bin ballerina zum
hafen angekommen und ich wollte mich
eigentlich jetzt hier so hinsetzen oder
hinstellt damit will das foto hier
machen aber da oben sind mega fette
spinne das netz bis hierhin war es still
jetzt in diesem aufbau so ja gut meine
hände sind dreckig haben es verstanden
haben fertig gestellt ist und wieder bei
mir in der wohnung angekommen normen
geht jetzt danke übrigens an schuhe die
mir einmal so ein kleines mikrofon fürs
iphone zugeschickt haben und einmal
einem eckball da hatte ich noch keine
oder auch dank anbieter für die
klamotten aber ich bin cool ich würde
sagen wir schauen wir was unsere
genetische vorne so macht und zwar audis
von indirekten reingegangen also so
sieht die knete hier geradeaus
ich habe auch gesehen dass in der
anleitung stand dass man die halt
irgendwie so zu dem ball machen kann
also irgendwie so unseren höfen im flur
auf jeden fall erstmal mit max ins gym
und danach ist es ja ein relativ dunkel
da würde ich sagen gucken wir mal
täglich im dunkeln leuchtet ich bin
nicht so spät ich genau dreimal blog
gelaufen
training beendet kelly max und andere
youtuber gehen jetzt noch hin papier
nebenan wo wir mal so eine par-runde
haben aber ich gehe jetzt nach hause
duschen von neid freunde ich das nicht
mehr ersten gleich nach dem jugendstil
werden wir uns mal die gesellen nacht
leuchten durch meter ansteuern müssen
als bisher zum ende des blogs irgendwas
hier immer sechs meter aber ich musste
halt auch die nachbarin also freunde der
sonne wir haben all oder halt freunde
des mondes weil das ist gerade nacht
außen es war für meine frisur aber ich
komme aus der dusche
das hier ist auf jeden fall jetzt die
knete die hat sich tatsächlich nicht
verändert wird gedacht ganz gerade extra
so ein bisschen dunkler gemacht haben
ich werde jedoch noch irgendwelche
machen also hier ist auf jeden fall die
knete trainiert man hier raus nehmen und
mal so ein bisschen nochmals durchkneten
wenn wir die knete auf jeden fall mal
wieder nehmen und so hinschmeißen seht
ihr schon die hüpft wieder wie so ein
flummi und ich würde jetzt mal sagen
dass ich die knete ich einfach noch ein
bisschen und da das licht halte weil ich
weiter mein gott das kannst du nicht
darum mit ins grün alter die knete jetzt
circa finale minute immer noch drunter
gehalten oder das licht und jetzt würde
ich sagen ich mochte nicht schalte macht
das licht aus und wir sehen
nein nein nein freunde egal
das hätte ich nicht gedacht was geht
guck mal wenn ich die kritiker als ihr
seht mich einfach nicht es stockfinster
und wenn ich so fern ist es wirklich
stockfinster beim wtl hier seht ihr die
kneten wenn ich das richtig und jetzt
mal wieder so an mache wenigstens es ist
einfach was das hätte ich nicht gedacht
freute das habe ich wirklich nicht
gedacht also das war so eine typische
verpackung so aus dem kindermagazin wir
nach chemie mit kindern war das
funktioniert wirklich alt hat ihre ist
das bitte
dekra ist dieses zeug an der stelle
würde ich den heutigen blog jetzt
allerdings auch beenden ich bin übels
capo nach dem training wieder und muss
jetzt auch schlafen weil ich das morgen
meine bachelor abschluss ball da ich
halt morgen die ganze zeit auf dem bei
sein werde und danach den tag
wahrscheinlich noch in meiner familie
unterwegs sein werde werden morgen
definitiv kein blog kommen also
übermorgen auch nicht aber dafür könnt
ihr jetzt ja eventuell man die
kommentare schreiben was wir stattdessen
sehen wollen also ob das jetzt
irgendwelche gamestop dass irgendwas ein
formales inka reagiert keine ahnung also
schreibt die kommentare was sie die
nächsten tage von mir die auf diesem
kanal sehen wollte und würde ich mich
natürlich sehr bei einem daumen hoch von
euch unter diesem blog hier freuen weil
das weiß natürlich mal als clown mit der
knete fand ich jetzt gerade sicher dass
auf jeden fall schon beeindruckt und
sonstwo dies haben wir uns dann in einem
anderen video wieder die klage in
kleinen block aber einem anderen video
zu lösen
[Musik]